the duke se crée un monde l'artiste
guyancourt toiser passionnés de
fantastique
influencé par tolkien et marion zimmer
bradley est sculpte des personnages
mignons ou effrayants j'utilise de la
terre noire généralement que je patine
après avec des produits qui s'apparente
aux produits qu'on utilise pour
travailler sur le bois et j'y inclus
souvent des éléments extérieurs que je
chine dans les brocantes des éléments
plutôt de vieux métiers utilisé par le
cordonnier les formats chaussures ont
des vieilles lunettes
les machines à écrire des choses comme
ça the duke travaillent la terre depuis
près de 30 ans mais elle se met à la
sculpture depuis une dizaine d'années
pour cette exposition elle rassemble des
animaux qu elle dote d'une intention
humaine dans le regard ou dans la
position prendre le regard des gens que
ses sculptures attire le regard
le regard des gens et une interaction en
fait c'est ça de façon l'ars et provoqué
une émotion chez le spectateur et moi
cette émotion elle passe par le regard
par le côté parfois un peu effrayant
parfois drôles des pièces que je
présente pour légendaire une quinzaine
de pièces et rassembler et certaines
pourrait vous surprendre